hi guys I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
breakdown of the walking dead season 7
episode 3 the cell and this episode
finally answered a few big questions
we've had about the savior's and dwight
in the sanctuary it's also giving us a
reliable wake up song for our alarm
clocks whoo God I'm weak awake - stop it
- stop playing that I know things kind
of slowed down a bit this episode but
you know what we are going to crack this
we're gonna break down all the stuff
that you missed and explain the hidden
meaning even if I sound a little insane
seriously some of these Walking Dead
episodes are like those magic eye
pictures we're just gonna like look at
them with a little crazy eyes to see the
big picture
uh-huh it's boobs it's always boobs okay
let's get started with the opening
images this episode opened with one of
the most surreal sights we've ever seen
on the Walking Dead the opening credits
of who's the boss know it's not too
often that we see working TVs in the
zombie apocalypse last screen of any
kind that I remember was back in the CDC
in season 1 but who's the boss actually
seems like a weirdly appropriate title
sequence for what's going on right now
so not to be confused with who's the
boss which is my upcoming autobiography
on shelf soon who's the boss was this
classic 80s sitcom about this crass
jokey retired baseball player Tony Danza
who moves in with this family who's used
to their independence as he tries to
assort his new authority and yeah I kind
of think that's meant to parallel negan
who carries around a baseball bat moving
in on these independent people insane
he's the boss now
in fact these shots of a van pulling up
to the house and Danza knocking on the
door kind of seem like a sitcom a
version of the shots of negan arriving
to Alexandria next episode I didn't
really watch that show but I'm pretty
sure there's an episode where Tony Danza
crushes Alyssa Milano's skull with the
baseball bat no I was a family matters
guy but that idea of figuring out who's
the boss and who's not comes back
throughout the episode and by the end
we'll have a very clear answer - who's
the boss now moving on in this whole
opening sequence we're seeing the
sanctuary joining in Alexandria and the
hilltop and the Kingdom the sanctuary
further brought into the walking dead
map it's the home of the saviors and it
looks like a very faithful adaptation
from the comics it's an old factory
surrounded by this pit of walkers with
its own running electricity and
specific social hierarchy then I'll talk
about a second but before I do let's
talk about this opening music
no this is not the theme song of who's
the boss this is town called malice by
the jam and according to the songwriter
the lyrics are about growing up in
England in the 80s under Margaret
Thatcher when working-class towns were
crushed economically by what they saw as
Thatcher's cruel regime and listen to
these specific lyrics
[Music]
this song is paying the picture of a
place that's the opposite of a warm rosy
home life where instead resources are
taken from you and you can never really
run away from it a town called malice
and these opening shots to pick the
sanctuary as that same town called
malice from the song it's not this fair
place where wealth is shared instead
there's kind of a strict class structure
where the stronger take what they want
and if you want to fight against it you
see that malice firsthand and just to
prove to you that I'm not making this up
about Margaret Thatcher in England check
out what brand of mustard that is
Thatcher now a lot of you guys have been
asking what really is going on in the
scene and what's the deal with the
number 39 well I have a theory that
everything in this music video might be
cobbled together from a bunch of other
deleted scenes that we didn't see that
would have established a lot of these
characters and who they are but here's
my interpretation of things we find out
later from negan that the Savior's whole
society is based on earned points it's
kind of like their currency you could
add yourself work for points but you're
gonna wish you were dead so I'm thinking
that Dwight is watching this guy who
might be completely out of points who's
begging for food literally taking the
shirt off his back and then of course
the Savior's reject him beat him up and
Dwight writes down this guy's address is
bunk number so that's why we see him
shortly after at the same place looting
this guy's stuff and notice how that kid
has long red hair which is the same
color as the guy who got beaten up I
think that might be his son and his
pregnant wife and by the way this shot
of everyone kneeling to negan it's taken
directly from the comics this is the
kind of weird social hierarchy that the
Savior's adhere to now I just love how
this montage especially when you pair it
with who's the boss it establishes
Dwight as a guy living in his own
ultimate reality eighties sitcom he's
watching TV playing drinking game air
hockey and then making the tastiest
homemade sandwich ever like I kind of
wanted him to say now that's a sandwich
and then like Burkle comes and knocks it
over can I do that
guys I'm still waiting for that Walking
Dead Family Matters crossover let's make
it happen but doesn't all this kind of
feel false in fact I think all this is
meant to connect back to the opening
montage of episode 12 last season which
had a similar upbeat song
with Carol making food and trying to
distract herself with this false
illusion of domestic life in the same
way I don't think this is a real home
for Dwight it's a prison cell he keeps
his head down he pays his dues he even
passes a time with these little carvings
just like the inmate in Shawshank
Redemption and that idea
Dwight being a prisoner is reinforced
when this montage comes to an abrupt end
so Dwight looks out of the Walker pit in
front of the sanctuary which is also a
defensive tactic used by the Savior's in
the comics and notice how Dwight stares
at this one Walker sliding up and down
this pole he feels a strange connection
with it so just like this Walker
Dwight feels like a dead trapped soul a
Walking Dead who can't even walk away
freely he can only move up and down the
totem pole as he operates as a tool for
Nagin and of course the title this
episode is the cell and that obviously
refers directly to Darryl's prison cell
but I also think it applies to Dwight's
imprisonment which I'll point out more
as we go okay moving on to this gross
dog food sandwich that Dwight feeds
Darryl few things about this one it's
interesting how its shot in the same
overhead tasty video way and I think
that's intended to parallel Dwight
sandwich
so remember Darryl is not in the comics
and the show created his character by
borrowing a lot of his characteristics
from Dwight who is in the comics so now
that both of these guys are in the show
I kind of feel like there's this natural
tension between them like they're kind
of twin doppelgangers competing for the
same slot also the fact that he's
feeding Darryl dog food continues that
runny metaphor I pointed out in the
season premiere of negan and the
Savior's trying to break in Rick and his
people like dogs
I don't select the way Darrell just wolf
sit down and that may be a callback back
to episode 9 of last season if you have
to eat [ __ ] that's not nibble bite chew
swallow repeat it goes quicker okay
moving on when we come back from the
credits we hear a new song
yikes this would not be on Daryl's road
trip playlist so this song is called
Easy Street it's by the collapsible
Hearts Club and a songwriter Jim Bianco
said that it was about quote those rare
moments in life when you were holding on
to the winning card
so pretty much insult to injury for
Daryl right now by the way I think this
is great the songwriter also said that
he didn't know why the Walking Dead
would want to use his happy song and
he's actually pretty amused and thrilled
to see it used as torture in the show
and this tactic of depriving inmates of
sleep by blasting loud obnoxious music
at random intervals is a real thing it's
an enhanced interrogation technique used
in places like Guantanamo and it's
designed to break them down
psychologically in fact according to one
former Guantanamo detainee
one popular track was britney Spears's
hit me baby one more time so the people
who do this stuff of a real sick sense
of humor but great taste in music now
it's still kind of a mystery why Daryl
wears a sweatshirt with the letter A on
it those other two guys have F NS on
their shirts so here's my theory so we
know that the savior's have this strict
class system and social hierarchy and
induction into this society requires you
to swear loyalty to negan by saying that
you are negan who you negan and letting
go of your former name so I'm thinking
that by labeling these people with
letters of the alphabet that might be
part of the process of stripping them of
their identity and the letters of the
alphabet could correspond to how far
along you are in that breaking in
process with a beam for beginners who
are still kind of resistant or it could
be kind of a priority thing like with
Daryl being higher priority because
negan has taken a peculiar liking to him
and my other theory is that when he put
all these guys together in a line it
like spells a word like safety or uh ass
pops yeah I'm gonna go with that
and speaking of letters notice how
sherry calls Dwight D hi dee hey now I
don't Lehman's coincidental I post white
and Darryl's name begins with D so being
reduced to this letter reminds us how
much these two are in competition and by
labeling Dwight as just a letter the
show is now treating him the same way
he's treating the letter labeled
prisoners like Dwight and then s and F
and understand White's arc this episode
it's important to go back and look at
episode six of last season that's where
Darryl first met these two when they
were still on the run
with Tina trying to escape the savior's
but now both Dwight and Shari feel shame
that Darryl sees them back in negan's
cage instead of the bold Runaways they
were when he last saw him it's that same
kind of aqua Ness to seeing that [ __ ]
bully from high school but like at the
mall on the weekend and then you see
that his dad is an [ __ ] too and the
bully's a victim just like you and
you're like oh good
still hate your guts now I'll come back
to these pregnancy tests in a bit but if
you're wondering what dr. Carson was
talking about when he said sorry still
getting used to being my own system he's
referring to primo that's the medically
trained Savior that Rick executed at the
end of episode 13 last season who tried
to escape on Daryl's motorcycle so this
episode is connecting a lot of these
dots between characters and events kind
of filling out this world and speaking
of that the gun that Rick used to kill
primo and his gun for all of the Walking
Dead is now in the hands of fat Joey
like if you look closely that's the same
Colt Python revolver it seems like negan
like divvied up all of their weapons
among the Savior's so I'm wondering
where Michonne samurai sword ended up
also this Walker that thing effin thing
s trained up outside that's the same guy
who took off his shirt and fought back
against the Savior's in the opening
montage so Dwight is using him to send a
message to Daryl that if he doesn't play
ball people who are part of the savior
community can still be turned into
walkers okay so moving on did this scene
with Dwight and negan and I realized by
watching the scene that we never seen
negan without Lucille so obviously he's
obsessed with that bad but I find it
interesting that the show never shows
one without the other it's like she's a
part of his personality like the source
of his power and this conversation that
they have actually clears up a lot about
the Savior's like we now learn why
Meighan said to Dwight in the season
premiere no you don't feel there not
until you try a little negan wanted
white to try to break in Darrel first
and then over the radio we hear about an
orange situation and we learn from negan
later that orange is their code for a
savior who has tried to run away we also
get a hand at negan's creepy views
toward women and sex in the sanctuary by
giving Dwight permission to have sex
with anyone that's applying that all the
women in the sanctuary are his property
and even though he adds that they have
to consent it's still implying that all
sex under negan's roof has to be like
approved by him now negan has a very
interesting marriage arrangement in the
comics that I don't get into yet and
we'll see if the show goes in that
direction but either way
is super messed up and it's pretty
clearly inspired by real like cults
specifically the Branch Davidians was an
infamous cult led by David Koresh who
considered himself God and had several
wives now Christian his followers holed
up in a heavily armed compound in Waco
Texas that ended in a deadly fire and
shootout with the feds in 1993
so if negan and his people seem a little
too crazy for you just know that these
types of crazies do exist in the real
world and they don't even need a zombie
apocalypse to make them that way also
now that we know negan's relationship
with Sheri that pregnancy test it seems
way more sinister so we find out later
that Sheri married Megan is spared
whites life and that along with the idea
of her carrying Megan's child must be
totally emasculating for Dwight that's
why he looks at negan with such contempt
when he offers that blast from the past
with Sherri and why negan bluntly asked
about his penis injury after eugene's
um mouthful negan is trying to
emasculate Dwight even further so with
the Savior's all rolls downhill and
negan is just as oppressive to his own
people as they are to others so Dwight
may be the boss of Daryl but Dwight is
in his own person so in fact notice how
eager white is to go outside looking for
Gordon even though a nigga's own words
it's grunt work this isn't just because
Dwight goes back with Gordon this
connects to the idea of Dwight's
imprisonment he wants to feel the
freedom of being outside the sanctuary
walls kind of like real-life convicts
who work in chain gangs and clean up the
side of the road before we move on check
out this shot of the angel statue
outside the sanctuary it's covered with
these severed arms and notice how
they're all cut at the same length that
negan drew the line on Carl's R this
implies that negan might have used that
same tactic in the past and in those
cases he was willing to actually make
people go through with it
okay moving on so as Dwight comes across
this pile of Walker's who fell from the
overpass check out this one now a lot of
people are saying that his hair and I
guess his face makes him look a bit like
Donald Trump
now of course AMC denied this but Greg
Nicotero has used facial replicas of
real people before like himself and
Johnny Depp in episode 12 of last season
but seriously come on I feel like this
comparison is kind of mean-spirited so
my apologies to the zombie then I'm out
moving on
notice how the way Darrell gets caught
matches the way that the Savior's
encircled Rick and his crew in the
season finale we even get a bit of that
same whistling from negan
who repeats his famous first line in
that scene this one our pants yet are we
missing our pants yeah so check out how
when negan tries to intimidate Daryl by
swinging Lucille at his face negan says
you don't care now this is a really cool
callback way back to Woodbury when
Darryl's brother Merle was trying to
intimidate Glenn by saying the same
exact thing you don't scare easy do you
and it's kind of like the ghosts of both
of these characters are here in this
moment with negan channeling Darryl's
brother and Daryl channeling the friend
he got killed in the same way also this
may just be coincidental but that was
episode 7 of season 3 which is the
inverse of this episode episode 3 of
season 7 so I really think that these
two moments are intentionally mirroring
each other okay let's fast-forward this
scene with Dwight catching up to Gordon
now remember that was a savior we saw
kneeling next to Dwight in the opening
montage that's why when he kneels again
for Dwight he says this is the last time
I'm going to kneel now he is done with
being negan's prisoner and his words
resonate with Dwight because they've
known each other since before the
Savior's and both of them had wives that
were kind of taken from them and now
they're both not entirely on board with
negan now Dwight ends up killing Gordon
because a he knows negan will just kill
Gordon anyway when he gets back to the
sanctuary but also be Gordon force
Dwight to realize a truth about living
under negan that it's really a prison
cell that's why when we see Dwight
return to the sanctuary he checks in
with Cherie as they both try to reassure
each other that being in this prison is
worth it a lot better than being dead
now moving on let's talk about the scene
between Dwight and Daryl now if you
remember I had a feeling after the
season premiere that we would see that
Polaroid of Glen's bashed in head come
back and sure enough here it is so why
does white do this and why does he
change a song to crying by Roy Orbison
see Dwight understands how similar in
parallel he and Darrell are and for the
first half of this episode
both of them were feeling anger directed
at their bosses the ones imprisoning
them Dwight taunted his prisoner Darrell
with this annoying song and dog food
sandwiches while negan taunted his
prisoner Dwight threw emasculation
but then Gordon triggered a new emotion
in Dwight Shane so Dwight knows that by
making Darrel feel shame he can rattle
him just like he feels rattled so he
changes that
join song into a song about real regret
over a lost loved one and it works it's
also interesting that Dwight says this
line don't pretend like you don't know
the score ever I compared to white to
Carol earlier and in that same episode
with Carol we saw her adding up numbers
to the number of people she had killed
and in that same way that Carol felt
shame for her score Dwight feels shame
for being negan's monkey and now he's
trying to pass that shame onto Daryl
okay moving on I love this shot here so
check it out when Dwight looks down on
Daryl Daryl is lying face down with the
vomit pulled up in front of him next to
the photo of Glen Daryl is posed exactly
like Glennis in that photo with his
brain splattered out in front of them so
it's interesting how daryl is at rock
bottom and now his misery is connecting
him with his dead friend at the moment
of his death and then we learn in this
thing with negan that Dwight's face got
burned with an iron which was actually
foreshadowed back in the season 7
trailer and that iron and jeffrey dean
morgan steidel slide but i gotta say it
was a little bummed that we didn't get
to see this actually happened to Dwight
or maybe we could have seen negan
punished Gordon in that same way and
then we could have cut - Dwight's face
and then we could put two and two
together I know I know the show has
desensitized me I feel nothing shut up
and then the climax of this episode
comes as Daryl defies negan by saying
his own name
Daryl now saying his full name is
clearly a Power Move it's not just
against negan it's against Dwight
because Dwight has been reduced down to
a letter D but Daryl proves he's more
than just a letter and he's more than a
prisoner working his way up within his
imprisonment like Dwight is Daryl still
has his identity and in the final line
of the episode Daryl turns the tables on
Dwight he tells him I get what he did
and it could refer to Tina's medication
or the scalding hot iron to the face but
the results are the same
Daryl sees a common humanity in his
counterpart they both have endured this
pain and torture for someone they care
about now the difference is Dwight's
conclusion was to serve as negan's loyal
prisoner whereas Daryl's conclusion is
to rebel because kneeling to negan would
endanger his friend and dishonored
Glen's memory so when Daryl says this
Dwight begins to feel like more of the
prisoner while Daryl begins to feel
more of a free man so to answer that
question from the top of the episode
who's the boss Darrell is and that leads
me to these closing images so Dwight
looks out in the yard unnerved by
Darrell's words and he sees Gordon now
chained up as a Walker in the pit and
just like the eerie connection he felt
with the Walker at the beginning of the
episode Dwight is now haunted by the
sight of his former friend just like
Gordon
Dwight feels trapped in mobile client at
this cage that he'll never escape from
and that's because he has chosen the
life of a prisoner with the sanctuary
being his cell okay some lingering
questions one does The Walking Dead have
room for both Darryl and Dwight so
Dwight has one of my favorite characters
in the comics and I know the show kind
of reassigned a lot of his cooler traits
to create Darryl for the show but I
really hope they don't turn Dwight into
another one of these like Nicholas type
characters who we see become a good
character just before he just gets
killed off please don't do that to the
white and to do you think negan is scary
enough now I know we're learning how
cruel he is to his own people
but Jeffrey Dean Morgan has been like so
likable and goofy and this episode he
really held back from doing that
punishment so even though he just killed
two major characters in a really brutal
way I'm waiting to see whether the show
wants us to like Pierre negan's every
move and gesture or if we're meant to
just like enjoy watching him I don't
know maybe I'm overthinking this let me
know what you think in the comments now
for those of you impatient viewers who
are like come on let's just move on with
the consequences and the fallout of the
main storyline because next week's
episode service looks like it'll come
home to Alexandria including this iconic
frame from the comics of negan banging
on the town's gate okay thanks for
watching and let me know what you think
in the comments and also make sure to
check out our breakdowns of past Walking
Dead episodes including episodes 1 & 2
of this season and please hit like and
subscribe to new rockstars and share
this video with your friends you can
also contribute to us on patreon thank
you so much to all of our current donors
especially Kevin chaw Han I hope I'm
saying that right sorry from not you are
awesome man thank you so much and for
the rest of you if you aren't currently
a patron we'd love your support you can
follow me on twitter at EA boss or new
rockstars on twitter at new rock stars
alright thanks for watching bye
[Music]